[Musique]
la solidarité continue dans les yvelines
le département a reçu des dons de 110
villes 20 semi remorques eux vont
bientôt partir pour l'ukraine plus de
650 places d'accueil sont également
référencés dans tout le département
l'île de france est le premier désert
médical du pays et les yvelines ne sont
pas épargnés elle recense seulement 943
généralistes pour 1,4 million
d'habitants le lycée international de
saint germain en laye a été
officiellement inauguré sa rénovation
est achevé depuis quelques mois après
trois ans de travaux l'établissement
accueille 2300 élèves de la maternelle à
la classe terminale
les chiffres du pôle 19 en yvelines sont
en hausse depuis l'allègement des
mesures sanitaires en moyenne 2600 qu'un
quotidien ont été recensées la semaine
dernière soit le double en une semaine
les admissions à l'hôpital ont quant à
elles augmenté de 20% les 150 ans de la
naissance de léon blum ont été célébrées
à jouy en josas pour l'occasion une
conférence et un débat sur l'héritage du
président ministres et hommes politiques
étaient organisées léon blum a vécu cinq
ans dans la ville avant son décès
[Musique]